- My name is Michael Novak.
I'm 34 years old and I'm a dancer
with the Paul Taylor Dance
Company in New York City.
I have what I call the recipe,
which is something that I've built
over a number of years of dancing.
The first is a cross training program.
And that can involve weightlifting,
Gyrotonics, yoga, some
kind of aerobic activity
like swimming in the pool, cardio.
Second part is getting
ready for the rehearsals.
And that can range from
taking daily technique classes
which can be ballet or modern,
going over all the
dances that I have to do
in a given day,
which can range from one
dance to six or seven dances.
The third one is performances.
So performance day is a bit different
because we have what's
called a tech rehearsal
where we basically run the
entire show before the show.
So I tend to not do weight training
or any kind of intense
physical preparation
before a show because it's about the show.
I try to save as much
energy for the performance.
The fourth thing is recovery time.
And this is something that
I've been implementing
as I get older and as my body
you know starts to change.
That recovery time becomes more crucial.
So I started dancing around age 10,
and around the age of 13 or 14,
I started to develop a severe stutter.
And for about a year and a half,
I was intense speech therapy to regain
my ability to speak.
Because I couldn't talk,
dance became a way for me to communicate
and to get out all the frustrations
and all the feelings that I had inside
that I couldn't get out.
And around the age of 18,
you know when you're in high school
and you're trying to decide
what you wanna do next,
I thought I wanna go to college
and I wanna get a degree in dance.
I was accepted to the University
of the Arts in Philadelphia
on a full ride scholarship.
I started to develop shin splints
pretty close to when I
started taking ballet classes
because of improper technique.
And I, as a dancer,
just pushed through the pain
and was like I'm gonna be fine,
I'm gonna persevere and
overcome all obstacles
and it will be great.
The shin splints kept getting worse
and I ended up developing
stress fractures in both shins.
The combination of the stress fractures
and being on my feet you
know 80 hours a week,
and not really making a
lot of money at the time
was really hard on me emotionally.
And to the point that I burned out.
I quit.
I was done.
I was gonna go back to school.
But while I was at Columbia,
I started to get this itch to dance again.
I studied a lot of dance
history, dance theory,
dance criticism, and I was reminded
of how much I loved the dance field
and the industry and
especially its history.
And I think that passion,
the understanding for the history of dance
really kind of rekindled the flame
to actually have a dance career.
And towards the end of my college career,
I decided you know what,
I'm gonna give it one more shot.
I'm gonna see if I can
actually make this happen.